alright here's a funny question sir this
is from Jeff Sloan and Jeff says just an
interesting thought that I had that I
would like you to explore or completely
debunked if objects moving faster than
the speed of sound can cause a sonic
boom is it at all possible that the Big
Bang was a result of something traveling
faster than the speed of light if I'm
correct please provide an address where
I can pick up my Nobel Peace Prize
look at first of all the Peace Prize is
not given for discoveries in physics
that would be the Nobel physics prize
aha just to clarify that they go jaffi
sorry buddy no Peace Prize for you no
matter what no matter what occasionally
a scientist can win a Peace Prize but
it's rare it usually goes to a
politician in power right or a dissident
in power right so so what do you want so
he wants to know if you can get a sonic
boom a light boom yes basically a light
bulb is Amy's talk the answer is yes
it's called shrink off radiation dude
you are killing me yeah yes if you go
travel if you travel faster than light
there is the light equivalent to a sonic
boom where the light pulse gets gets up
builds up on itself and it's a flash of
light and holds your rank off radiation
now but since you can never travel
faster than light right you might ask
how does one come up with this stuff
exactly here's how it works if you have
light traveling through water
transparent water light travels slower
through water than through a vacuum any
trouble so let's start the fastest in a
vacuum jobs a little throat slower going
through hair right comes a little slower
good only through water right guys even
slower going through glass travels even
slower going through diamond okay and
then of course that is because it is
both a wave and a part
yeah it's trying to get through the
money think through the video through
the pen in fact the diamond I remember
my number it's 40% as fast in a diamond
as in a vacuum
yes it's slow huge that is right that's
what makes diamond so cool so if you put
facets in the diamond at the right
angles right at the correct angles
because the right angle would be
degrees at the correct angles because
what we call the index of refraction is
so large because light travels so slowly
in a diamond that it bends back on
itself multiple times within the angles
that you can create on your ring and
then it shows up again in a different
direction
so that's why a diamond looks like it
sparkles because if it was only by
coming from where the light came from
you so that's just the light I'm looking
at but it comes from a new angle you say
hey that diamond is sparkling is talking
to me right so all right so now you have
light going through all these media now
you sent a particle through there faster
than that speed that will create a mini
sonic boom except it's not sound it's
like a mini light boom and was first
described by the physics in a chair in
coffee and he won a Nobel Prize for this
discovery look at that that's raikou so
so tell me nobel prizes already me it's
already been sorry Jeff your your prize
has been played okay you were right with
somebody beats you to Mission wait wait
but let me get back to the Big Bang so
the Big Bang was an expansion of the
universe faster than white but it's not
the universe expanding faster than light
in a medium gotcha it is very fabric of
space and time itself expanding and you
don't get trick of radiation from that
okay right because it's actually
happening in the vacuum which is space
well no I mean all space is the
explosion it's not a vacuum within the
space okay so the space itself is the
explosions explosion gotcha gotcha duh
look at that you know that stupid yes
okay I